Donald Trump's press secretary Kaley
mcenany was asked at her Monday press
briefing by reporters whether Donald
Trump plans to resume the coronavirus
press briefings and she didn't answer
the question but the answer is obviously
no and it's a good question to ask
because we're seeing massive coronavirus
hot spots growing very rapidly in the
United States mostly different areas
than the early hot spots and I'm going
to talk about the virus itself shortly
but there's a real media story here to
understand we talked about the bully
pulpit of corporate media much of what
is in the national discussion the top
three stories that are in the national
discussion at any given time are
essentially led by corporate media and
this is called agenda setting power it's
not necessarily that corporate media
tells us what to think about any
particular issue although sometimes they
do but it's that corporate media tells
us what to think about what to talk
about and I'll give you an example
remember kids in cages the immigration
scandal it's still going on but it's
rarely if ever in the media except to
mention that some people being held at
the border have contracted coronavirus
but nothing has fundamentally changed
about that story which was wall-to-wall
coverage previously during this
administration now it's like it doesn't
exist then it was coronavirus we have a
pandemic daily press briefings including
Donald Trump and doctors pouchy and
Bert's
daily updates down to the specific
details about the number of masks and
project air bridge flights from Mike
Pence and then the White House signaled
we're going to stop Trump wondered aloud
about injecting bleach and isopropyl
alcohol to treat coronavirus it became
clear that the White House didn't really
want more visibility for doctors Burks
and Foudy talking about the virus so the
briefing stopped and with that over time
as more and more states have decided to
reopen some are safely reopening some
are very unsafely reopening the topic of
the virus itself started to take a
backseat especially as the George Floyd
killing took place and the massive
protests started and now as we're seeing
the protests
sir starting to die down a little bit
but the big topic has become defund the
police or do not defund the police
depending on whose perspective you're
listening to right-wing media saying
defunding the police would be anarchy
some on the Left furious that Biden does
not want to defund the police but
understand that nothing materially has
changed with coronavirus we'll look at
the data put it up on the screen now
fortunately as you can see we've seen a
leveling off and a slow decline in the
number of cases at the national level
but mostly what we're seeing is the
cases being relocated where we are
finding new hot spots understand that at
the peak we were finding 25 to 30,000
cases a day we are still finding 19 to
25 thousand new cases every single day
and the number of active cases meaning
people who currently have the virus is
still as high as it's ever been and yet
Donald Trump barely talks about
coronavirus his press secretary barely
talks about coronavirus right-wing media
is done with it other than calling it a
scam or a conspiracy and even corporate
media is increasingly talking about
coronavirus less and less but we have a
new political article that points out
not only is the pandemic still very much
a pandemic with no effective treatment
no vaccine we have new hot spots that
are setting records for new cases there
are parts of the country that are
exploding with virus cases and Donald
Trump is just silent another massive
failure because Trump by not talking
about it makes people think the threat
is over
meaning they go out and behavior
responsibly and cause even more cases
and in fact as we talked about yesterday
on the bonus show Donald Trump is
planning to restart his huge mag or
alleys as part of his 20/20 re-election
campaign in a couple of weeks so I'll
give you some really specific examples
Texas which started to reopen pretty
quickly is exploding week to week they
have more and more cases the number of
active cases in Texas is higher today
than it has ever been
Florida run by Republican governor Ron
de Santos
also started to open pretty early they
were caught lying about numbers as we
previously covered and after a small dip
sometime in April which might have just
been them lying they once again in
Florida are seeing record numbers of new
cases now I mentioned that the cases are
dramatically shifting from some parts of
the country to others this doesn't mean
you know Kings aren't going terribly
everywhere I am thrilled to say that
here in Massachusetts at least for now
cases have been very steadily declining
since late April the graph I'm showing
you you'll see a one-day spike about a
week ago that's not really a spike that
that was a bunch of presumptive cases
from the three months of coronavirus
were all added in on that day but we are
looking really good here and I'm
thrilled to see that so this is a story
not just about the virus itself which is
still raging with no treatment or
vaccine but it's a media story as well
about the agenda-setting power that
corporate media has we said six save
seven weeks ago Trump's strategy is
going to be just start pretending it
doesn't exist start talking about the
economy jobs reopening and a bunch of
corporate media has played along now in
the meantime things are so bad here in
the United States with coronavirus that
as more and more countries or reopening
travel the United States is being banned
I'll give you an example Iceland has so
dominated the virus that Iceland decided
that on I believe it's June 15th they're
going to reopen tourism when you get to
Iceland you have to have a kovat test at
the airport or quarantine for 14 days
people are going to be able to go to
Iceland and start doing tourism if
that's what they want to do except
Americans aren't going to be allowed
because things are so out of control
here other countries people are going to
be allowed to start going to Iceland not
Americans because it's a disaster and I
wouldn't be surprised if this continues
as the virus keeps spreading in
different US states other countries are
going to be increasingly controlling it
not Brazil India you know there's places
that are that Russia that aren't
controlling it but more and more
countries are going to be allowed to
restart travel and Americans are going
to be banned from going to other
countries
because it is so poorly handled here now
as far as the framing and the propaganda
expect Trump soon to start arguing that
an Tifa and other left-wing protesters
are responsible for spreading the virus
if the numbers keep growing in a lot of
these new hotspots like Florida and
Texas I would anticipate that Donald
Trump will take the protests as the
perfect opportunity to say it's an Tifa
and lefties that are now responsible if
he even mentions it at all and to be
clear the protests will cause some
number of new cases what we're seeing
now is reflective of the situation 10 to
14 days ago and that's important to
remember be ready for it because it's
going to happen and don't forget we're
still in the middle of a pandemic which
some doctors believe is still in its
beginning phases which is overwhelming
to think about our sponsor Nord VPN is
giving you 70% off a three-year plan
which is just a little over three bucks
a month and you will get an extra month
free when you go to North Vee PN comm
slash David Pakman or just go to their
website and use the coupon code David
Pakman by this point in time if you're
not using a VPN when you're on the
Internet
you are putting yourself at a huge
disadvantage Nord VPN keeps your IP
address hidden when you're browsing
online keeps your personal data safe
from hackers prevents websites from
following you around the internet and
you can even use it on your phone
there are many different VPN options out
there but Nord VPN is the one I trust
because they don't log your internet
history they use military-grade
encryption and they encrypt your data
twice to double the anonymity Nord VPN
is giving you 70% off a three year plan
that's just over three bucks a month
plus an extra month free when you go to
Nordby pn comm slash david pakman i've
put a link right underneath the video or
just go to their website and use the
coupon code david pakman